I have to tell you it's more than a
little intimidating being up here
an old American guy trying to tell
Africans something new about your own
continent but sometimes an outsider can
see things in a different way like from
the air that's what I found by flying
low and slow all over the African
continent as I photographed the
spectacle of its diversity and I wasn't
always an old guy this is me in 1979 a
kid from California backpacking his way
through the Ituri forest of Zaire I was
on a year-long hitchhiking trip I just
dropped out of Stanford University and I
went from Tunis to ki-sun Ghana to Cairo
I learned how to live on $10 a day it
was an amazing experience for me I spent
about a week in this dinky cattle camp
on the banks of the Nile in South Sudan
the Dinka taught me how to tie papyrus
into a shelter and also I observed how
they had um had the adapted that way of
life around the migratory needs of their
beloved cattle it was like a graduate
course in ecological ethnography and I
got busy taking notes with a camera with
no money for rides they often made the
Mizzou GU ride on the roof of the trucks
or in this case on the top of the train
going across South Sudan I felt like I
was riding on the back of an insect
going across the enormous tapestry of
Africa it was an incredible view from up
there but I couldn't help but think
wouldn't it be even more amazing if I
could fly over that landscape like a
bird
well that notion stayed with me and in
20 years later after you come fresh the
photographer I was able to talk National
Geographic and doing a big story in the
central Sahara and I came back with a
new kind of flying machine this is me
piloting the world's lightest and
slowest aircraft it's called a motorized
paraglider it consists of a backpack
motor in a parachute style wing and it
flies at about 30 miles an hour with 10
litres of fuel I can fly for about two
hours
but what's really amazing about it is it
gives me an unobstructed view both
horizontally and vertically like a
flying launch here my hitchhikers do me
flying over Africa came true when I
spotted these two chemical bonds passing
out in the middle of Sahara the one in
the foreground is carrying salt out of
the desert while the one in the
background is carrying fodder for the
animals heading back in I realized that
you couldn't take this kind of picture
with a conventional aircraft an airplane
moves too fast
a helicopter be too loud with too much
downdraft and it dawned on means that
this this crazy little aircraft OS
flying would open up a new way of seeing
remote parts of the African landscape in
a way that never really been possible
for let me show you how it works
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks this may seem a bit dangerous but
I'm not some kind of adventure dude I'm
a photographer who flies and I only find
I take pictures
my favorite altitude is between 200 and
500 feet where I can see the world three
dimensionally but also at a human scale
I find that a lot of what I've done over
the years in Africa you could probably
you could try to do with the drone but
drones aren't really made for
exploration they only fly for about 20
minutes of battery life and about three
kilometers of range and all you get to
see is what's on a little screen in
front of you but I like to explore I
want to go over the horizon and find and
find new things find weird stuff like
this volcanic caldera in the air if you
look at the at the altimeter on my left
leg you'll see them about a mile above
takeoff flying that high really freaked
me out but if you talk to a probe pilot
they'll tell you that altitude is
actually a friend because the higher you
are the more time to figure out your
problems
as a rank amateur I figured just give me
more time to scream on the way back down
to calm myself down I started taking
pictures and as I did it became rational
again and I was getting buffeted by
harmontown moon trees coming out of the
upper right hand corner of this picture
and I started to notice how it filled
the entire crater was saying when I got
to the north of Chad I found a different
kind of volcano these it had their
entire exterior stripped away and
although his left was the old core and
in the middle of Sahara I felt like like
I was in this era I was seeing the
earthling skin stripped away much of it
Sahara is underlaying by an enormous
freshwater aquifer when you go to the
basin sometimes you can see it leaking
out if you were to walk through those
palm groves you could drink fresh water
out of your footsteps but that green
lake water due to extreme evaporation
it's saltier than seawater and virtually
lifeless in the air I was amazed to see
how the locals learned how to exploit a
different kind of desert spring here
they mix the salty mud with spring water
and spread it out in shallow ponds and
has it evaporated it turned into a
spectacle of color my rig is also
amazing for looking at era culture this
picture was taken in southern Algeria
where the locals have learned how to
garden in a mobile dune field by tapping
into shallow groundwater I also loved
looking at how animals have adapted the
African landscape this picture was taken
in Lake kam bacilli just across the
border from here in Kenya the elephants
have card the shell lake water up into a
network of little pathways and they're
spaced just set apart that only
elephants did along trunks get tapped
into the most succulent grasses in
Namibia the zebra have learned how to
thrive an environment that gets no
rainfall at all these grasses are
irrigated by the dense coastal fog that
blankets the area every morning and
those bald patches out there they call
them fairy circles and scientists still
struggle to understand what causes them
this is Mount visage
with a small crater lake in its summit
at 3,700 meters it forms the roof of the
Great Rift Valley and also the border
between Rwanda and Congo it's also the
center of the reserve for the fabled
mountain gorillas
they're actually the big moneymaker in
Rwanda and on this side of the border
Conservation has become a huge success
rwanda has the highest rural population
density in africa
and I saw it in around almost every
corner of the country I went to I've
heard it said that competition for land
was one of the things later the tensions
that caused the genocide of the 1990s I
went back to South Sudan a few years ago
it was amazing to see how much things
have changed the Dinka were still in
love with their cattle but they had
turned in their spears for coalition
AQAP's
the cattle camps from above were even
more spectacular I could have imagined
but things had changed there too you see
those little blue dots down there the
Dinka had adapted to the new reality and
now they covered their papyrus shelters
with the tarts moo-hyun food convoys in
Mali the Bozo people have learned how to
thrive in the pulsating rhythms of the
Niger River as the rainy season ends in
the water subsides they plant their rice
in the fertile bottoms in that village
and lower right corner that's gay one of
the jumping-off points for the major
trade routes across the sahara at the
end of the harvest the bozo takes the
leftover rice straw and they they mix it
with mud to reinforce the roots in the
village mosque
I must have fun over a dozen villages
like this along the Niger River and each
one was unique a different pattern and
each mosque was like a sculptural
masterpiece and no two were alike I've
flown all over the world and nothing can
really compare to the cultural diversity
of Africa you see it in every country
from Morocco to Ethiopia to South Africa
to Mozambique to South Sudan tamale the
array of environments and cultural
adaptations to them is really
extraordinary in the history is pretty
cool too from the air I have a unique
window into the earliest ways of
colonial history this is Cyrene and the
coastal mountains of Libya it was
founded by the Greeks in 700 BC as a
learning center in timgad which was
founded in what's now Algeria by the
Romans in 100 AD this was built as a
retirement community for old Roman
soldiers and it's it amazed me to think
that North Africa's once the breadbasket
of the Roman Empire but seven hundred
years after Tim dad was built it was
buried in sand and even then the African
climate was wetter than it is today the
African climate continues to change and
you
see it everywhere like here in the
Gorgias is where a freak rainstorm came
barreling out of the Sahara and Blanc of
the mountains in snow I never thought I
would see date-palms in snow but the
kids that day had a great time throwing
snowballs at each other but it made me
wonder how our Africans going to adapt
to this rapidly changing climate going
forward in a continent is dynamic and
diverse as Africa sometimes it seems
that the only constant is change well
there's one thing I've learned is that
Africans are the ultimate improvisers
always adapting and finding a way
forward thank you
[Applause]
[Music]